vous avez une jolie couleur de peau vous
savez
comment vous l'appelez cette couleur
ma couleur
[Musique]
ISO sage
se sont retrouvés avec les pires au
monde
et ils ont été plus malin que tout le
monde c'était des champs pétrolifères
leurs noirs
l'argent du pétrole coule à flot dans le
coin j'adore l'argent monsieur
[Applaudissements]
cette manne coule dans la bonne
direction
leur heure est venue
tout ça ne sera plus qu'une simple
trajectoire
quand l'argent s'est mis à pleuvoir
on aurait dû savoir qu'il avait un prix
aussi
on dirait des buzards qui survolent
notre peuple
on est encore des guerriers
[Musique]
et je me dis que je devrais tuer ces
hommes blancs qui ont tué ma famille
il faut que tu reprennes le contrôle de
ta maison
ah je suis je suis envoyé par Washington
je viens voir pour ces meurtres
vous venez voir quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'espère qu'un miracle va pouvoir
arranger tout ça
tu sais que les miracles ça n'arrive
plus
[Musique]